é derrière et donc il faut libérer les
commissaires à à - 5 a juste un escalier
à monté mais bonjour ta bah viens viens
en
face a François viens aussi
François madame le professeur monsieur
le professeur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui donc
deux éminents professeurs madame Daniela
Schwarzer membre du conseil
d'administration de la fondation
Bertelsman et professeur honoraire à
l'Université libre de Berlin et Monsieur
Olivier Costa directeur de recherche au
CNRS qui est chercheur au Centre de
Recherche politique de Sciences Po Paris
c'estvipof directeur du Département
d'Études Politiques et de gouvernance
européenne au Collège d'Europe au nom de
mes collègues je suis très heureux de
vous accueillir au Palais du Luxembourg
et je vous remercie d'avoir acceptter de
venir devant notre commission nous
présenter les conclusions de votre
rapport il y a peu de sénateurs
mais congrès des maires
explique probablement ce ce manque de
présence vous avez été en effet
corapporteur du groupe des 12 experts
franco-allemands sur la réforme des
institutions de l'Union européenne mise
en place en janvier dernier à
l'initiative de la secrétaire d'État aux
Affaires européennes madame Laurence bon
et de son collègue de sa collègue
homologue allemande madame Anna lurman
ministre adjointe chargée des affaires
européennes et du
climat il est en effet progressivement
apparu aux États-membres que l'élan vers
l'élargissement nourr par des
considérations géopolitiqu qui sont
évidents dans le contexte de la guerre
en Ukraine ne pouvait pas ignorer la
nécessité en parallèle de mettre l'Union
en capacité d'intégrer de nouveaux
membres potentiellement au nombre de 8
voire peut-être 10 si la Géorgie et le
Kosovo se voyaient aussi reconnaître le
statut de pays candidat le constat de
départ euh et je vous cite l'Union
européenne n'est pas encore prête à
accueillir de nouveaux membres ni sur le
plan institutionnel ni sur le plan
politique c'est un
constat il est heureux qu'une initiative
franco-allemande a ainsi été prise pour
réfléchir ensemble à ce défi quelle
réforme de l'Union européenne peut-on ou
doit-on envisager pour maintenir sa
capacité d'action protéger ses valeurs
fondamentales renforcer sa résilience et
la rapprocher des citoyens européens
dans la perspective d'un possible
élargissement mais aussi dans le Pr
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'Europe néanmoins je tiens à préciser
pour l'avoir rapporté avec ma collègue
Giselle Jourdin que ça n'a pas été un
sujet éminemment mis en avant sur les
questions de l'avenir de l'Europe après
plusieurs mois de travaux vous avez
présenté le 18 septembre dernier vos
conclusions et propositions dans un
rapport au titre bien choisi naviguer en
haute mer réforme et élargissement de
l'Union européenne au 21e siècle il a
été transmis au membres de notre
commission et je précise que vous avez
travaillé en toute indépendance et que
vos propositions n'engagent pas les
gouvernements ni français ni allemand si
nous devons souhaiter nous avons
souhaité vous vous entendre c'est parce
que notre commission a la conviction que
ce sujet de l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne et de la nécessaire réforme
de l'Union à mener au préalable s'impose
comme l'enjeu majeur des prochaines
élections européennes de juin 2024 mais
je ne sais pas si tout le monde en a
conscience votre audition tombe heureuse
coïncidence le jour même où les eurodép
eurodéputés doivent adopter eux aussi
eux aussi leur proposition de réforme de
l'Union européenne préparé par cinq
rapporteurs dont quatre allemands il
faut le
relever nous sommes donc
particulièrement intéressé d'échanger
aujourd'hui avec vous sur les
conclusions de votre rapport qui porte
sur des pistes pour assurer à la fois
l'avenir des politiques européennes et
un fonctionnement efficace des
institutions européennes qu'il s'agisse
de l'effectif de la Commission
européenne du système décisionnel au
sein du conseil ou encore de la
constitution du Parlement européen il
s'agit de proposition innovante par de
nombreux aspects votre rapport présente
le mérite de sortir des sentiers battus
audacieux il n'en est pas moins réaliste
je pense en particulier à vos
propositions pour rendre acceptable une
extension du vote à la majorité
qualifiée en créant un filet de sécurité
pour la souveraineté voir la possibilité
d'un opt-out réaliste aussi l'idée d'une
intégration différenciée avec une Europe
à quatre cercles au moins un noyau
restreint l'UE les membres associés puis
la communauté politique européenne cela
rejoint nos propres réflexions sur
l'intérêt du recours à la
différenciation je vous renvoie à ce
sujet au rapport d'information sur les
suites de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'Europe que ma collègue Giselle Jourdin
et moi-même avons soumis à notre
commission qui l'a adopté en juillet
dernier en effet dans une Europe à 27
aujourd'hui et peut-être 35 demain voire
plus
tous les États ne voudront et ne
pourront pas progresser au même rythme
et il sera indispensable de permettre à
ceux qui le veulent d'aller plus loin
dans la voie de l'intégration comme cela
a été le le cas avec l'euro par exemple
ou Schengen et en même temps il faudra
rendre substantielle l'intégration dans
le club européen pour d'autres États en
utilisant des flexibilités leur
permettant de participer par étape à
certaines des politiques européennes
c'est-à-dire en les accueillant dans
chaque pièce de l'édifice européen l'une
après l'autre mais cette différenciation
doit être encadrée et obéir à des
principes garantissant l'unité
européenne à cet égard vos propositions
méritent toute notre attention votre
rapport a aussi l'intérêt de présenter
plusieurs options possibles pour
modifier les traités en tenant compte
notamment des réserves de nombreux
États-membres à se lancer dans une
révision des traités et ils sont
nombreux tant l'incertitude est grande à
la fois sur le fruit qui résulterait
d'un tel processus de révision et sur la
capacité des des États-membres à faire
chacun ratifier la dite
révision je relève enfin votre
insistance sur le respect des valeurs
communes et de l'État de droit tant en
ce qui concerne les membres actuels de
l'Union européenne que les candidats à
l'adhésion en tant que juriste je serais
intéressé de savoir comment vous
appréhendez cette notion d'état de droit
cité parmi les valeurs de l'Union à
l'article 2 du traité cette notion n'a
pas de définition juridique précise
pourtant c'est en référence à l'état de
droit qu' a été construit le mécanisme
de ialité budgétaire qui est basée sur
l'article 7 du traité et que vous
suggérez d'étendre c'est aussi sur son
fondement que les institution
européennes justifie un contrôle de plus
en plus étroit des politiques menées par
les États-membres je pense au rapport
annuel que la Commission publie sur
l'état de droit depuis 4 ans quel
jugement portez-vous sur ces évolutions
enfin je voudrais regretter que la place
des parlements nationaux n'est pas été
mieux reconnu dans votre rapport vous
évoquez la création d'une chambre
commune des cours et tribun suprême de
l'Union pour les inciter à mieux
dialoguer mais les chambres
parlementaires nationales restent les
grandes oubliées du rapport alors
qu'elles ont un rôle important à jouer
pour approcher l'Union européenne des
citoyens madame le professeur monsieur
le professeur je vous laisse maintenant
la parole dans l'ordre qui aura votre
préférence pour présenter votre travail
avant de répondre aux questions de nos
collègues et Madame deidra a déjà pris
position
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président M m messieurs je vais parler
le premier pour dire quelques mots sur
le contexte de rédaction de ce rapport
et je laisserai Daniel Schwarzer parler
peut-être plus de substance et ensuite
on pourra peut-être enchaîner sur les
points que vous avez que vous avez
souligné vous avez déjà bien présenté la
la la raison d'être de de de ce rapport
qui est vraiment lié à la guerre en
Ukraine qui rebat toutes les cartes et
ouvre de nouvelles perspectives jamais
l'Ukraine et la Moldavie n'auraient
accédé au statut de pays candidat aussi
rapidement sans ce ce bouleversement
géopolitique jamais la Georgie qui
n'aurait pu accéder au statut qui va
peut-être lui être reconnu le mois
prochain sans cela et de la même manière
les les négociations avec les pays des
Balcans occidentaux auraiit pas été
relancé sans ce nouveau contexte donc ça
crée une forme d'urgence qui exige des
institutions européennes qu'elles se
mobilisent pour penser la suite parce
que en fait peu de gens l'ont fait ça
fait 50 ans qu'on a des rapports sur
l'avenir de l'Union européenne mais
c'est vrai que dans la période récente
il y a assez peu de gens qui se sont
penchés sur cette question et sur les
difficultés que vous avez souligné
monsieur le prés président notamment sur
la cette difficulté liée à l'unanimité
qui est nécessaire pour réformer les
traités et et les ratifier un autre
enjeu qui est très important c'est
l'affirmation somme tout nouvelle de
l'Union européenne comme puissance il y
a encore 5 ans c'était une idée qui
était relativement tabou à Bruxelles
d'affirmer que l'Union était une
puissance qui devait trouver sa place
dans le jeu international entre les
États-Unis la Russie et la Chine et
aujourd'hui il y a assez peu de gens
pour contester cette idée et donc là
aussi c'est une une chose qu'il faut un
petit peu peut mettre en musique l'idée
de l'Union européenne qui doit assurer
sa propre sécurité dans un monde qui est
devenu un peu plus dangereux et très
incertain et si Monsieur Trump et réélu
aux États-Unis l'année prochaine je
pense que on va devoir mener à nouveau
une réflexion sur la possibilité de s'en
remettre uniquement à l'autant pour
assurer notre notre sécurité donc il
faut repenser un petit peu l'Union
quelle union voulons-nous quelles
institutions pour faire fonctionner
cette union comment organiser
l'élargissement sans brader l'acqui
communautaire et et les valeurs de
l'Union euh et comment faire en sorte
qu'une union à 35 reste fonctionnelle
dans ce contexte qui demande de la
réactivité et une certaine capacité à à
prendre des des initiatives donc c'est
dans ce contexte là que que Laurence B
et lourman ont lancé cette cette
réflexion en nous demandant de rester
c'est très important uniquement sur les
institutions et pas sur les politiques
parce que tel est le mandat qui est le
leur en tant que membre du Conseil
Affaires général où on discute des
questions institutionnelles mais pas des
politiques publiques et il est évident
qu'il il faut mener toute une autre
réflexion sur la réforme des politiques
de l'Union européenne de ses priorités
budgétaires si on veut réussir à penser
l'avenir de de l'Union alors le groupe
qui a été créé été composé de 12 membres
six Français six Allemands des gens
issus des S tank des professeurs des
praticiens à la retraite avec un bel
équilibre des générations et des des
profils malheureusement pas d'équilibre
du genre puisqueon avait se femmes pour
5 hommes mais c'est assez rare pour être
pour être souligné on a travaillé de
manière très très légère on n pas
bénéficié d'un secrétariat on a eu peu
de moyens pour se déplacer euh et se et
se rencontrer mais d'une façon je pense
que ça a été aussi fonctionnel parce
qu'on a été obligé de prendre en charge
tous les aspects de de notre travail de
manière de manière très très autonome on
a travaillé essentiellement par des
réunions en visionférence deux fois par
mois on a produit un grand nombre de
notes détaillées qu' on tout été rédigés
par un membre français un membre
allemand du groupe et Daniel Schwarzer
et moi-même avons ensuite rédiger le
rapport sur la base de toutes ces notes
et de toutes les minutes de nos réunions
notre objectif était d'avoir un rapport
le plus court possible le le premier le
premier objectif c'était 20 pages c'est
ce que les ministres auraient bien voulu
finalement on est plutôt à 30 et on a
essayé de le rédiger dans un langage
relativement simple et accessible ce qui
fait que juridiquement c'est une un
élément de critique facile pour nos pour
nos collègues les les les plus affutés
mais c'est délibérément qu'on a choisi
de d'utiliser un langage qui soit
relativement accessible on a auditionn
une longue liste d'acteurs venus de
toute l'Europe et des pays candidats au
au cours de nos travaux mais on l'a fait
euh à hlos et sans en publier la liste
car certains ne souhaitaient pas y
figurer et ça a été très utile pour
tester un certain nombre d'idées de
proposition euh je ferai simplement
trois remarques sur notre travail la
première remarque c'est celle de
l'indépendance le président l'a dit euh
le rapport n'a pas été endossé par les
par les ministres et nous-mêm avons
travaillé de manière totalement
indépendante des des autorités
françaises et allemand on a aussi
travailler de manière bénévole ce qui
était une caution supplémentaire de
notre liberté d'esprit dans ce dans ce
travail on n'a pas vraiment rapporté euh
au cabinet ou au ministres on les a
rencontré deux fois dans le processus
mais c'était plus pour leur indiquer les
les thématiques sur lesquels on
réfléchissait que pour leur proposer
vraiment des solutions opérationnelles
et de la même manière on a fait un point
d'étape avec le Conseil Affaires
générales le 29 mai mais là aussi
Daniela et moi avons plus parler des
thématiques qui nous préoccupaient que
soumis euh des euh des idées dans le
cadre de ce travail nous n'avons pas
pris en compte euh les euh les intérêts
ou les positions français euh et
allemand l'idée était de réfléchir de
manière abstraite à l'échelle des 27 et
on n jamais eu de débat franco-allemand
au sein du groupe franco-allemand
c'était quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a
agréablement surpris on a aussi proposé
un certain nombre de choses dans ce
rapport qui ne vont pas forcément dans
le sens des des intérêts français et
allemand parce que si on veut penser à
la réforme il faut trouver un équilibre
qui permette à chacun d'y trouver d'y
trouver son compte et et donc le le
rapport n'a pas été à proprement parl
repris à leur compte par les mini
ministre mais je pense qu'il commence à
avoir un impact sur certaines de leurs
positions je dirais la même chose des
des ministres des Affaires étrangères et
dans une certaine mesure aussi de de
Monsieur Macron et de Monsieur SCHS
deuxème ensemble de remarques sur la
portée de notre de nos réformes ou de
nos propositions l'idée était vraiment
de trouver un équilibre je dirais entre
les positions de nombreux analystes qui
sont un peu déprimantes consistant à
souligner toutes les divisions qui peut
y avoir entre les 27 et l'impossibilité
qu'aucune réforme n'advienne et les les
positions qui sont beaucoup plus je
dirais ambitieuses qui sont celles
notamment du Parlement européen celles
dont il délibère aujourd'hui et qui qui
me semble assez peu susceptible d'être
massivement reprise à leur compte par
les États-membres donc on essayait de
proposer on a essay de proposer quelque
chose qui soit réaliste un ensemble de
solutions qui permettent peut-être de
contribuer à l'élaboration d'un
compromis parmi les les 27 alors les
questions dont on traite sont de
vieilles questions beaucoup de
propositions que l'on fait sont aussi
des idées qui circulent depuis un
certain moment mais notre idée était un
peu de revisiter tout ça à la lumière du
nouveau contexte de la de la guerre en
Ukraine qui qui crée un état d'esprit
très différent parmi parmi les 27 on a
pu le voir même je dirais en temps réel
lorsqu'on a fait une première
présentation de d'un certain nombre
d'idées le 29 mai on sentait une
ambiance relativement froide mais
lorsqu'on a présenté la version finale
du rapport
mi-septembre les choses avaient déjà
changé en l'espace de quelques mois je
dirais que même les les europhiles les
moins enthousiastes peuvent accéder à
l'idée qu'il va falloir faire une
réforme qu'on qu'on l'aime ou qu'on ne
l'aime pas que l'élargissement s'impose
peut-être plus comme une nécessité
géopolitique comme un
choix de société ou un choix par rapport
à l'intégration européenne et et donc je
trouve que les que les choses vraiment
avance avance très vite et sur les
politiques publiques parce que et le
budget ça c'est les prochains débats qui
qui qui doivent être entrepris là aussi
les choses sont très tendues pour
l'instant mais moi j'ai bon espoir que
là également le débat se fasse et
progresse assez euh euh assez rapidement
donc euh encore une fois on n' pas pu
évoquer dans le cadre de ce rapport la
question des politiques publiques et
évidemment c'est un c'est un grand
manque dans ce
rapport troisième remarque que que je
ferai et j'en finirai là c'est que je
crois qu'il existe aujourd'hui un
consensus au Conseil non pas sur les
réformes à entreprendre mais sur l'idée
qu'il va falloir en entreprendre et que
c'est possible et ça c'est une grande
surprise mais d'une certaine manière ça
n'a pas été une surprise pour nous parce
qu'on regarde aussi l'intégration
européenne avec un un œil d'historien si
on a un point de vue rétrospectif on
peut dire qu'à toutes les étapes de la
construction européenne c'était
compliqué parce que c'était pas simple
et néanmoins depuis 1990 on a eu quatre
réformes majeures des traités on a eu
quatre vagues d'élargissement et tout
ceci s'est fait avec les exigences
d'unanimité pour la négociation pour la
ratification donc les contraintes sont
les mêmes aujourd'hui plus il y a
d'états-membres et de joueurs évidemment
plus les choses sont sont complexes mais
je pense pas qu'on on puisse commencer
par dire que rien n'est possible
évidemment il y a des leaders nationaux
qui sont moins qui ont moins d'aétence
pour un élargissement monsieur Orban ne
s'en cache pas il y a la problématique
budgétaire avec les les États-membres
d'If rugo mais je pense qu'il y a rien
d'insurmontable dans tout cela et qu'il
faut vraiment explorer sérieusement et
concrètement les possibilités d'une
réforme si on veut que cette réforme
puisse intervenir je donne la parole
maintenant à à Daniel Schwarzer merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs
je vais vous présenter nos principales
recommandations pas toutes parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup mais nous sommes prêtes à
répondre à toute question que vous aurez
alors d'abord la question du choix parce
que le rapport a dû être court et on a
dû choisir beaucoup de de réformes entre
beaucoup de réformes possibles et donc
on a défini d'abord des objectifs des
réformes et on a choisi des propositions
qui renforcent au moins un des trois
principes que je vais je vais vous
présenter d'abord accroître la capacité
d'action de l'Union européenne notamment
vu le contexte géopolitique Olivier
vient de de souligner deuxièmement
préparer les institutions à
l'élargissement évidemment c'est dans le
mandat de notre groupe et troisièmement
renforcer l'État de droit et la
légitimité démocratique je vais
commencer par ce troisème principe parce
que c'est aussi le premier grand
chapitre dans notre rapport alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a commencé le
rapport avec ceci tout d'abord on a
parlé de l'État de l'Union européenne
tel qu'on l'observe aujourd'hui parce
que dans notre principale hypothèse de
départ c'était on va on va proposer des
réformes qui préparent l'Union
européenne à l'élargissement mais on
trouvera aussi des propositions qui sont
de toute manière utiles à l'Union
européenne et notre revue des faiblesses
de l'UE telle qu'elle se présente
aujourd'hui c'est notamment le fait
qu'elle ne puisse pas défendre le
principe d'État de droit efficacement au
sein de de l'UE des 27 donc on a
beaucoup discuté de l'Hongrie de la
Pologne qui maintenant a est en train de
choisir un autre en fait de mettre en
place un autre gouvernement qui peut
renverser les réformes du gouvernement
pis mais de toute manière c'est un grand
souci euh pour l'État de l'Union
européenne que l'État de droit qui est
la base du marché intérieur que ce
principe est remise en question
c'est-à-dire l'indépendance judiciaire
au sein des États nationaux deuxièmement
la reconnaissance de la primuté du droit
européen et la reconnaissance du rôle de
la Cour de justice
européenne alors on a deux éléments de
proposition d'abord on a étudié de près
la
conditionnalité budgétaire qui a été
introduit à avec le Fond Européen de
reconstruction je connais pas
l'abréviation française c'est next gen
eu en anglais euh vous saurez de quoi je
parle alors c'était à notre avis un
principe efficace et à revisité
notamment lors de la définition du
nouveau cadre financier de l'Union
européenne on était d'accord dans le
groupe que la légitimité de de cette
démarche est donnée notamment pour les
États membres qui sont sur le côté
donateur du budget européen que les
citoyens de ces états-là doivent
s'attendre à ce que l'argent soit
dépensé dans des conditions d'État de
droit et de transparence et donc on
pense que cette proposition ne sert non
seulement à renforcer euh l'État de
droit le principe de l'État de droit au
sein de l'UE mais aussi euh d'aider à
ajouter de la légitimité politique aux
dépenses
européennes deuxièmement on a proposé
d'améliorer la procédure euh visée à
l'article 7 du Traité du sur dans
l'Union européenne et ce principe si il
est réformé a besoin d'une réforme des
traités évidemment tant que l'autre peut
se faire dans le cadre d'une décision
politique au Conseil euh la révision du
droit primaire est nécessaire pour
changer l'article 7 alors on propose de
remplacer le vote à l'unanimité moins
une voix par une vote à la majorité des
4/5è du Conseil européen c'est-à-dire
que euh il est plus simple plus facile
de sanctionner un État membre
deuxièmement on veut renforcer le cadre
automatique de la réponse en
introduision des délais contraignant le
conseil et le Conseil européen à statuer
une fois la procédure ouverte
aujourd'hui on observe que les délais
sont très longs ça dure énormément de
temps et pour
avoir plus de poids politique il est
très important d'avancer plus rapidement
et trème élément qui s'ajoute à ce Dee
point c'est prévoir des sanctions
automatique 5 ans après toute
proposition visant à déclencher la
procédure est faite et donc là un
automatisme dans les 5 ans qui suivent
l'ouverture de la procédure euh on a on
a mis euh ces propositions vraiment en
premier chapitre parce que c'est un
principe qui doit être renforcé pour
tout ce qui suit après donc si on veut
maintenir l'union européenne tel qu'on
la connaît aujourd'hui si on veut
maintenir le marché intérieur l'Union
européenne doit être capable de défendre
ce principe de base
le 2e chapitre porte sur les défis
institutionnels et on a identifié cinq
domaines clés à réformer euh on on a
parlé du Parlement européen et notamment
on suggère de ne pas élargir le nombre
maximal des députés qui sont
actuellement
et donc on propose d'adopter un nouveau
système de répartition des sièges fondés
sur la formule de Cambridge ensuite pour
le conseil européen euh pour le Conseil
de l'Union européenne on a on a regardé
la le fonctionnement notamment de la
présidence de l'Union européenne euh la
présidence qui se fait sur une période
de de 6 mois euh on on trouve que c'est
un élément très important à la fois pour
la gestion euh du Conseil des ministres
mais aussi pour euh chaque État membr
d'avoir un ownership euh des affaires
européennes et de pouvoir communiquer de
son propreô au sein de l'UE vis-à-vis
ses propres citoyens mais on pense que
la coordination des présidences du
Conseil européen peut être renforcé et
on propose notamment d'avancer du format
de trio c'est-à-dire trois pays membres
qui se coordonnent sur une période de 18
mois d'avancer sur C présidences donc 2
ans et demi ce qui veut dire la moitié
du mandat de la Commission européenne et
et du Parlement européen donc comme ça
on pense qu'on pourra mieux coordonner
les initiatives politique les coordon
mieux avec le programme de travail avec
la Commission européenne et d'avoir plus
de cohérence sur les 5 ans entre deux
élections
européennes pour la Commission
européenne on on a Cho on a choisi de de
parler notamment de la taille et de
l'organisation du collège déjà
aujourd'hui avec 27 commissaires c'est
c'est c'est un c'est une organisation
très complexe et grande et le collège
si on l'imagine à à à 35 commissaires
commence à devenir trop lourd il faudra
inventer des dossiers supplémentairire
pour chaque pays qui arrive et chaque
commissaire qui serait là le traité de
Lisbonne offre la possibilité de réduire
la taille du collège donc sans réforme
du traité on pourrait réduire le nombre
de des commissaires on a présenté ça
comme première option mais on est très
consciente du prix politique que ça peut
avoir si un pays membre n'a pas de de
commissaire pendant une p période de de
5 ans donc notre deuxème option qui à
notre avis est
politiquement plus
facilement négociable c'est différencier
les commissaires en fait différencier
entre commissaires principaux et
commissairire si vous voulez normaux et
donc une une certaine
hiérarchisation sans nécessairement
réduire le droit de vote si on
choisirait de de réduire le le droit de
vote c'est-à-dire euh identifier un
groupe qui a les droits de vote au sein
de la Commission et les autres qui ne
l'ont pas il faudra reformer le droit
primaire et donc on ne propose pas ça
parce qu'on pense que c'est trop
difficile finalement on a aussi euh
parlé du processus de décision au
conseil et là vous avez déjà évoqué le
le principe du vote à la majorité
qualifiée pour nous
euh c'est un élément très très important
notamment pour avoir plus d'efficacité
euh pour les décisions au sein du
conseil et on s'est entretenu longuement
avec des gens qui qui sont vraiment très
proche du fonctionnement du Conseil qui
nous ont parlit notamment des mécanismes
de prise de décisions et la conclusion
vous avez déjà évoqué n nos
recommandations principales je veux
juste euh ajouter un élément
d'explication on a bien compris par des
conversations que même si la majorité
euh qualifié n'est pas appliqué mais
existe ça peut avoir un
effet favorable à la construction d'un
consensus entre les États-membres c'est
pour cela qu'on pense que même si on
introduit euh ce ce
fameuse cette protection de la
souveraineté nationale et évidemment la
possibilité de transférer des décisions
au Conseil européen on pense que ce
qu'on propose aurait un effet de de
discipline politique c'est-à-dire de
fond formation de consensus entre les
États-membres finalement euh je vais
vous parler de nos propositions pour
renforcer la démocratie à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne on propose
l'harmonisation des lois électoral au
sein de l'UE c'est-à-dire entre les
États-membres parce que aujourd'hui euh
et ce sera le cas en 2025
2024 les conditions dans lesquelles les
élections se déroulent au sein des
États-membres ne sont pas harmonisés et
on propose des mesures très concretes
pour arriver à cet objectif
ensuite on a des on propose des éléments
de démocratie
participative il y a déjà beaucoup
d'éléments qui ont été testés au sein de
l'Union européenne on pense que c'est un
outil très très très très valable pour
renforcer la démocratie représentative
qu'on ne remet pas du tout en question
mais on on rappelle qu'il est très
important que ce soit clair et
transparent dans quel dégré les
résultats de toute mécanisme de
participation de citoyens soit repris
par les institutions européennes parce
que si on invite à la participation
ensuite il n'y a pas de procédure clair
et transparente d'utiliser ces résultats
ça va ça ça va pas aider à la légitimité
de du déroulement finalement on propose
aussi de d'utiliser ces instrument de
participation pour préparer
l'élargissement donc on propose
concrètement pour chaque question qui
intéresse les citoyens des état candidat
ça peut être utile de les impliquer dans
les décisions parce que ça peut déjà
construire un débat trans-européen avec
les futurs membres ça qu' peut commencer
on peut commencer la la socialisation
politique dans la réflexion à l'échelle
européenne et on ne voit pas de de
contrainte politique ou ou légal à à
cette démarche finalement pour la
question de probité transparence et la
lutte contre la corruption qui est un
grand sujet notamment pour le Parlement
européen on propose de créer un nouvel
office de la transparence et de la
probité chargé de superviser les
activités de tous les acteurs
travaillants dans ou pour les
institutions de l'Union
européenne on a ensuite des chapitres
sur les compétences et attributions de
l'Union européenne et des ressources de
l'Union européenne en raison de temps je
je vais juste évoquer qu'on c'était pas
dans notre mandat donc on a approché ces
deux questions d'un point de vue
institutionnel et décisionnel et donc on
fait des propositions qui tiennent
compte de la nouvelle situation à la
fois géopolitique euh extérieure de
l'Union européenne mais aussi des défis
intérieurs qui se sont quand
même des défis qui qui se sont agrandis
à cause des crises qu'on a vécu au sein
de l'Union européenne où à notre avis le
budget doit répondre à de à à des
nouvelles tâches on propose donc
d'introduire des nouveaux mécanismes de
décision de dépenses mais aussi de
regarder de très près ce qu'on a appris
sur les
ressources du budget européen notamment
avec le bon exemple du du fond next
generation eu
je vais peut-être m'arrêter là je vais
demander à Olivier si tu veux ajouter
des points je oui merci beaucoup Daniel
juste pour répondre aux deux questions
du du président rappin sur l'état de
droit on s'est pas lancé dans une
définition on avait des juristes dans le
groupe et si on les avait lancé sur
l'affaire le rapport frerait 200
pages on s on était simplement d'accord
pour dire que que cette question de
l'État droit qui a pas forcément
toujours été très centrale dans les
réflexions sur l'intégration européenne
l' est vraiment devenue nous nous-même
dans le groupe on éétait pas convaincu
que ça soit aussi central que ça et on
s'est finalement à force de travailler
sur ce sujet on s'est dit que c'était
absolument fondamental et que notamment
on refusait l'idée qu'il soit possible
de détacher intégration économique et
État de droit c'est une idée qui est un
peu dans l'air que finalement on
pourrait revenir à un simple marché et
et laisser tranquille les responsables
politiques nationaux et finalement gérer
les choses comme ils l'entendent chez
eux mais on on est vite arrivé à la
conclusion que sans État de droit il
peut pas y avoir de de de marché unique
parce que sinon on ne peut pas éviter
les distorsions dans l'application du
droit européen on ne peut pas garantir
les droits individuels des citoyens
européens qui irait travailler ou
étudier ou vivre dans un autre État
membre on ne pourrait même pas donner de
sécurité juridique au aux opérateurs
économique qui irait signer un contrat
ouvrir une entreprise et serait
dépouillé de leurs bien ou de leurs
droits parce qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'indépendance de la de la justice et
c'est pour ça qu'on lui a donné un rôle
très central dans euh dans le rapport
sur ce qui est dans le rapport et ce qui
n'y est pas on a été obligé de faire des
choix assez difficiles pour tenir les 30
pages et donc il y a certaines
thématiques très importantes qu'on n pas
évoqué pour deux raisons soit parce
qu'on y croyait pas par exemple un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
cours au Parlement européen sur les
listes transnationales pour les
élections européenne pour le droit
d'initiative du Parlement européen sur
la fusion des postes de président de la
Commission et du Conseil européen on
estimait que toutes ces réformes étaient
porteuses de peut-être plus de problèmes
que que que que davantage et il y a
d'autres sujets sur lesquels on n pas on
n pas travaillé tout simplement parce
qu'on estimait qu'on avait pas
grandchose à ajouter à ce qui est
proposé et c'est le cas du rôle des
parlements nationaux dans le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne il
y a beaucoup de propositions et de
rapports qui circulent ici et là des
idées par exemple comme le carton vert
nous semble tout à fait positive mais on
n'avait rien d'intéressant à dire sur le
sujet mais mais j'attire peut-être
l'attention de la de la commission sur
le rapport qui a été récemment publié
par SEPs sing Tang qui est à Bruxelles
un rapport dirigé par Calypso nicolaid
su rousac et Nicola vanarta Sophia et
Nicola sont deux membres du groupe des
12 et qui est un rapport qui porte
spécifiquement sur la question
démocratique qui envisage cinq ensembl
des réformes pour améliorer la
démocratie dans l'Union et qui donne une
large part à la question du rôle des
parlements nationaux dans la gouvernance
européenne
merci je reviens juste sur un point
concernant ce que vous avez dit sur
finalement l'évolution de l'Union et et
et et les choix les choix qui sont faits
pour le futur on a aussi au-delà des
crises guerre en Ukraine covid et cetera
qui ont fait progresser l'Europe vers
l'Union européenne vers en tout cas
peut-être plus de compétences ou des
compétences mieux assumé il y a aussi et
c'est incontournable et ça rejoint
finalement la question sur les
parlements nationaux les politiques
intérieures de chaque état-membres et
l'évolution des mandats politiques qui
sont donnés au gouvernant de C ces
États-membres
les relations que l'Union peut avoir
avec aujourd'hui compliqué quelquefois
je pense à la Pologne je pense à la
Hongrie c'est aussi lié à la politique
interne de ces états donc ça aussi c'est
vraiment intégré dans la notion et quand
je dis ces états ça concerne aussi les
parlements nationaux de de ces états sur
les sur les parlements nationaux avant
de passer la la parole à nos collègues
ici on a beaucoup travaillé pendant la
présidence française sur cette question
avec la façon dont on on
peut mieux organiser la relation entre
les parlements nationaux et et et les
institutions
européennes se borner et se réduire à à
la COSAC de rendez-vous par tous les 6
mois par
semestre à chaque présidence c'est c'est
c'est pas c'est enfin c'est pas
acceptable c'est pas acceptable en tant
que tel il faut vraiment une implication
plus forte ça c'est ma conviction
personnelle elle durera le temps qu'elle
durera mais en tout cas ma conviction
durera mais en tout cas elle sera portée
je l'espère par la suite parce que c'est
quand même un enjeu très fort de de la
de la vie européenne de la vie
européenne en tant que telle surtout si
en plus on intègre encore quoi donc être
très attentif à
ça bien on commence Martha tidrac et
puis Claude Kerne se prépare et puis
audre
lineneld merci beaucoup président merci
à Monsieur Costa et schfarcer d'être
présent parmi nous et d'avoir d'ors et
déjà répondu à un certain nombre de
questions que je vous aurais volontiers
posé mais que je compléterai par par
d'autres déjà pour commencer je trouve
que le titre de votre rapport est tout
un programme quand on l'appelle naviguer
en haute mer réforme élargissement on
comprend quelle était la difficulté de
la tâche à laquelle vous vous êtes
attelé euh et donc moi je vais
directement vous poser une question j'ai
j'ai lu peut-être pas suffisamment dans
les détails euh votre rapport et
notamment je vais m'arrêter je vais
prendre ça comme porte d'entrée votre
page 16 où vous avez un petit schéma et
un petit triangle dans lequel vous
indiquez quels sont les trois objectifs
finalement qui que vous vous étiez
imposés dans cet exercice euh pour
pouvoir faire un certain nombre de
recommandations beaucoup de ces
recommandations pour ma part euh sont je
les ai traduites un petit peu comme des
recommandations relativement technique
en fait pas forcément facile à
comprendre euh quand on n'est pas plein
dans le sujet donc dans ce triangle vous
avez trois sommets évidemment accroître
la capacité d'action préparer les
institutions à l'élargissement monsieur
Costa dans vos propos liminires vous
avez évoqué aujourd'hui une forme
d'urgence justement et que c'était
finalement cette porte d'entrée qui a
initié d'une certaine manière cette
réflexion autour de cette réforme
institutionnelle et puis le troisème
sommet qui est celui de du renforcement
de l'État de droit et de la légitimité
démocratique pratique c'est là-dessus
que je voudrais revenir en prenant en
m'inspirant des propos de notre
président
Rapin notamment au sujet des parlements
nationaux et du Parlement de l'Union
européenne en tant que tel puisque
l'Europe aussi ce sont des États-membres
et ces États-membres on des citoyens
sont constitués de citoyens européens et
cela me semble important de le rappeler
à chaque fois et donc de de la
représentation au sein de nos
institutions européennes de ce qu'est le
citoyen européen c'est quelque chose qui
m'a manqué un tout petit peu ça rejoint
d'une certaine manière la réflexion du
président Rapin lorsqu'il dit les
parlements nationaux quelle place leur
octroyez-vous dans cette réflexion
comment en réalité nous parlementaires
qui sommes les représentants de
nos de nos
concitoyens pouvons à un moment donné
exprimer aussi cette démocratie au sein
de cette instance européenne qui me SEM
enfin au sein de cet espace européen qui
me semble très important
notamment par ces temps un petit peu
trouble que nous traversons et du coup
je rebondis sur les propos de Madame
Schwarzer lorsque vous dans les
différentes recommandations et dans les
différentes propositions que vous faites
vous évoquez la création d'un office de
la transparence et de la probité je
crois que c'est comme ça que vous l'avez
intitulé dans votre rapport et je me
pose une question parce Queen plus vous
dites ça serait peut-être même bien
qu'on transforme cet office en
institution une autre institution
européenne mais au fond ne pensez-vous
pas que si les parlements européens les
parlements nationaux pouvaient être
mieux entendus avoir plus de place dans
la réflexion européenne dans son
ensemble en réalité on pourrait sans
doute répondre à un certain nombre de
questions puisque quand même n'oublions
pas que ce sont les contribuables
européens d'une certaine manière qui
financent aussi nos actions européennes
et ce qui permet de de rebondir sur les
sujets de l'accroissement de l'action
que vous souhaitez en fait et que sur
lequel vous faites des recommandations
voilà je ne veux pas être trop longue
mais c'est vraiment ce sujet de la
représentation je vais le dire très
simplement de l'échelle du citoyen d'un
état-membre au sein de l'Europe parce
que aujourd'hui on voit on est à la
veille d'élection importantes et on va
voir de nouveau nos citoyens qui vont
nous demander plein de choses sur
l'Europe qui ne vont pas comprendre qui
Contin continuent à toujours pas
forcément bien comprendre en quoi
l'Europe union évidemment est présente
dans leur quotidien voilà je vous
remercie et pardon d'avoir été un peu
long ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
prenne toutes les questions comme vous
êtes deux comme ça vous pourrez vous
répartir les les réponses en fonction
des voilà Claude Kern et audre linconel
qui se prépare merci président
alors Monsieur le Professeur merci pour
votre présentation et je voudrais vous
poser deux questions une question de de
fond que vous traitez d'ailleurs dans
votre remarquable rapport que j'ai un
peu vous avez déjà un peu répondu en
diagonale mais je pense
que ça mérite peut-être un
approfondissement c'està-dire que
au-delà des mérites et de la capacité
des pays candidat aujourd'hui à faire
les réformes qui sont nécessaires pour
s'adapter à à l'acqui
communautaire et aux exigences de de l'
l'adhésion quelle est votre évaluation
de la capacité d' tion de l'Union
européenne je pense que ça c'est une
question de fond et puis quelque chose
qui m'a frappé dans votre rapport
également c'est la
gradation gradation intéressante puisque
elle renouvelle la théorie des cercles
concentriques chers à ubert vidrine
l'adhésion doit-elle être un tout ou
rien peut-elle au contraire être
progressive et selon quelle
modalité audre linonel des Val Boyer se
prépare merci monsieur le Président
bonjour à tous les deux et euh
félicitations à mon tour pour pour la
qualité de votre rapport euh j'ai pour
ma
part quelques remarques et et quelques
questions également certaines qui vont
dans le sens de ce qui a pu être dit
précédemment euh d'abord dire que je
trouve particulièrement intéressante la
réflexion qui est la vôre et les
recommandations qui en découlent autour
de de la notion de de droit et comment
on peut en effet fortifier et protéger
l'État de droit à l'échelle européenne
tout en envisageant son élargissement
toutefois je dois reconnaître que je
vous trouve de ce point de vue
relativement optimiste en tout cas plus
que moi et je suis pour ma part pas
complètement certaine que ces éléments
là soit soi suffisants quand on voit et
cela a été dit un peu la désaffection
qui est celle des citoyens européens à
l'égal de des institutions et de
l'Europe et de l'idée européenne en
général et je ne suis pas sûre que les
prochaines élections démentent ce que je
suis en train de dire je ne suis pas
sûre que ça soit suffisant non plus
quand on voit la montée des des
nationalismes en Europe euh
conséquence au dommage collatéral de la
désaffection je n'en sais rien mais en
tout cas c'est une réalité donc j'aurais
bien aimé vous entendre là-dessus euh
souligner peut-être ê finalement un
petit paradoxe que je note dans vos
recommandations vous nous dites à juste
titre d'ailleurs que l'élargissement
apparaît finalement d'abord comme un
choix
géopolitique renforcé après les les
événements en Ukraine avec quand même
comme paradoxe que dans vos
recommandations le seul sujet qui reste
soumis à l'unanimité c'est la politique
étrangère et de sécurité commune on peut
comprendre pourquoi mais quand
l'élargissement est d'abord le un choix
géopolitique plus qu'un choix économique
social euh on peut en tout cas c'est mon
cas noter aussi ce paradoxe qui m'amène
à vous poser deux questions la première
c'est quel est le regard que vous
portez depuis le 7 octobre sur les
recommandations que vous avez pu faire
sur les constats que vous avez fait
notamment sur cette question d'un
élargissement comme un choix
géopolitique je fais évidemment
référence à ce qui se passe euh en
Israël et en Palestine donc on a vu que
l'Europe avait euh eu du mal à se
positionner sur les question sur ces
questions-là et qu'il y a y compris au
sein du couple franco-allemand parfois
euh et c'est pas nouveau des des
divergences sur les positionnements
voilà donc quel est le quel est votre
regard au regard des des propositions
que vous avez fait est-ce qu'il y a des
choses que vous diriez euh autrement euh
aujourd'hui euh euh depuis ces
événements est-ce qu'au contraire il y a
des choses que qui qui vous confortent
depuis ces éléments et dernière petite
question vous avez indiqué je crois que
c'est Monsieur Costa qui l'a dit que
vous étiez heureux qu'il n'y ait pas eu
de de débat franco-allemand entre vous
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
quels sont les sujets sur lesquels vous
pensez qu'il y aurait pu y avoir un
débat franco-allemand étant moi-même
franco-allemande et ayant l'occasion
d'aller très prochainement à deux
reprises dans des dans des échanges
franco-allemands ça m'intéresserait que
euh vous nous en disiez davantage même
si euh officiellement il n'y a pas eu de
débat
merci Valérie Boyet Didier Marie se
prépare merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président moi je vais être je pense plus
Simp peut-être plus direct que ce que je
j'ai entendu et vous me pardonnerez
peut-être ma brutalité mais je fais mes
premier pas dans cette commission euh
j'ai toujours pas compris comment euh on
pouvez intégrer l'Union alors qu'il y a
des conflits euh gelés ou qu'il y a des
conflits d'ailleurs pas gelés donc
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'explique comment
c'est possible euh deuxème point euh
bientôt on va discuter de la Georgie là
Saur de ma part euh ces deux conflits
gelés euh et troisème point je reviens
avec certains de mes collègues de
d'Arménie euh où nous étions avec l'OSCE
on sait qu'il a ça fait très longtemps
que l'Arménie aurait aimé
un geste un regard enfin quelque chose
qui la sorte de son isolement abominable
face aux Turcs aux azériis à l'abandon
des russe
euh comment la Georgie qui a pu avancer
sur le chemin de l'Union
euh pourquoi on nirait pas plus loin
pour pour l'Arménie euh sauf à à
considérer que c'est quelque chose de
totalement abandonné que les
Azerbaïdjanais vont faire ce qu'ils vont
vouloir ce qui est probablement ce qui
est en train de se dessiner
malheureusement euh enfin c'est pas une
question de de c'est pas une supposition
c'est qu'une question de date si
personne ne fait rien
et mais cette question sur l'intégration
et les conflits gelés moi me j'arrive
pas à comprendre et enfin euh pour vous
dire que je souscris totalement à ce que
vient de dire notre président euh je
crois qu'on peut plus continuer à parler
d'Europe sans avoir l'assentiment
l'explication des parlements parce que
je crois que c'est pas le sentiment
anti-européen qui nous qui gêne les
Européens c'est plutôt le sentiment
antiinstitution européennes et la
supranationalité de ces institutions qui
gênne nos concitoyens mais il me semble
peut-être que je me trompe en tout cas
mon sentiment puisqu'on parle de
sentiment c'est que les Français et
probablement les autres peuples d'Europe
se sentent européens mais ne comprennent
probablement pas les agissement et le le
dogmatisme ou peut-être le
l'administratif des institutions
européennes merci Valérie Didier Marie
et Giselle jourd qui se prépare merci
président merci beaucoup pour la
présentation de votre rapport et et et
le travail qui a été mené
euh moi je partage effectivement bon
nombre des postulats que vous avez mis
en avance sur la nécessité du respect de
de l'État de droit qui a peut-être été
euh
insuffisamment mis en exerg précédemment
euh et et donc pour le faire respecter
la conditionnalité des Z ce qui a été
testé dans le cadre du plan de relance
avec succès je trouve même si on n'est
pas encore au bout et et bien évidemment
sur la question du changement du
principe décisionnel et et la fin de
l'unanimité pour la plupart des sujets
euh ceci étant euh j'ai euh deux
inquiétudes euh la première c'est celle
du calendrier
euh est-ce que vous considérez qu'un
certain nombre d'éléments que vous
proposez peuvent être mis en œuvre avant
le
renouvellement de du Parlement européen
et de la mise en place d'une nouvelle
commission c'est-à-dire d'ici grosso
modo novembre 2024
euh deuxièmement si cela semble
difficile au regard des échéances
politiques nous connaissons euh et
notamment des échéances nationales dans
un certain nombre de pays et
d'états-membres
euh pensez-vous
que il
soit aisé de trouver une majorité pour
faire avancer le chmilblic comme dirait
l'autre
euh ça c'est la la la la première
question euh de la même façon euh vous
faites un certain nombre de propositions
qui peuvent pe se faire dans le cadre
des traités actuels mais vous soullignez
qu'un certain nombre d'autres ne pourrai
se faire que dans le cadre d'une
révision des traités selon vous quelles
sont les conditions à
réunir pour
permettre d'engager cette
révision ce doit cela doit-il se
faire par
consultation des citoyens européens cela
doit-il se faire par procédure
intergouvernemental ou par tout autre
possibilité sachant
que la première solution euh est la plus
démocratique mais la plus porteuse de
risque euh et que bien évidemment à
l'inverse si on passe par les procédures
intergouvernementales les citoyens
considéreront que c'est encore ce grand
machin européen qui
fonctionne par par lui-même enfin
dernier sujet
euh
évidemment la question d'élargissement
est revenue au cœur des débats du fait
de l'agression russe en Ukraine et
çaavère certainement encore plus
nécessaire aujourd'hui avec ce que nous
connaissons depuis le 7 octobre ceci
étant est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que ce choix géopolitique qui s'impose à
l'Europe est partagé par l'ensemble des
États-membres
Giselle assez vite Giselle parce que est
des réponses je vais essayer d'être
rapide bon c'est vrai que quand on
arrive la fin on peut pas développer moi
mes mes questions seront extrêmement
clair c'est que je souhaiterais savoir
dans le cadre de pays qui avait
contractualisé donc avec l'Union
européenne dans le cadre donc du
Partenariat oriental je pense notamment
à la Moldavie à l'Ukraine et à la
Géorgie et pour
avoir défendu à ce moment-là donc c'est
ces contrats d'association je
souhaiterais savoir dans le cadre de la
procédure d'élargissement que vous avez
donc évoqué comment on fait les
politiques d'évaluation parce que à un
moment on se lance dans des contrats
puis tout d'un coup on passe sur une
autre
donc étape mais j'aimerais bien savoir
comment on quantifie l'étape primaire
parce que les partenariats oriental sont
en cours avec ces trois pays ensuite mon
autre question portera sur
sur quelque chose qui est à mon sens qui
doit être souverain c'est que lorsqu'on
parle des de la décision des états de
vouloir rentrer dans une procédure
d'élargissement on parle des
gouvernements mais est-on bien sûr que
les peuples concernés soit vraiment dans
la
problématique nous avons participé avec
le président Rapin à la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'Europe mais eston bien sûr
que ce soit le choix des populations
donc concernées
je vous laisse le swin d'y répondre
j'espère avoir été breève très très bien
Giselle en plus avec des questions bien
opportune par rapport à celle qu'on se
pose sur le travail de la commission
euh donc Madame et Monsieur les
professeurs vous avez 25 minutes pour un
grand
oral je serai bref je vais répondre à
toutes les questions faciles et je
laisserai les autres à ma
camarade monsieur le Président vos
questions vous avez raison d'insister
sur le fait qu'on est dans un jeu à deux
niveaux et c'est pour ça je pense qu'il
faut garder l'esprit l'esprit ouvert
personne n'aurait pu peu de gens a
parier sur un changement de majorité en
Pologne c'est un changement qui va avoir
des répercussions majeures sur la
possibilité de de négocier une une
réforme des traités et des conditions
d'un d'élargissement al je pense pas que
le gouvernement va devenir Eurofil
soudainement mais on sera pas dans dans
dans une situation polarisée comme on a
pu la connaître ces dernières ces
dernières années alors ça peut aller
dans les deux sens hein
rien on n'est pas à l'abri non plus de
de changement de gouvernement dans des
pays qui pour l'instant sont sont
pro-européens mais d'une certaine
manière il faut se donner la possibilité
que quelque chose se passe si rien n'est
préparé ce qu'il faut éviter de faire
c'est ce qu'on a fait un peu dans les
années 2000 à savoir que l'Union
européenne attendait que les États
candidats soi prêts les états candidats
d'une certaine manière attendaient que
l'Union soit prêt et personne n'était
prêt et et l'élargissement s'est fait
dans des conditions je dirais
suboptimales avec un traité de réforme
qui est arrivé après les élargissements
et avec des états candidats qui
n'étaient pas tous au niveau quand ils
sont rentrés dans dans dans l'Union
européenne sur la place des parlements
nationaux alors encore une fois on en a
pas parlé dans le rapport mais on s'est
mis assez vite d'accord les 12 experts
pour reconnaître l'Union européenne
comme un système politique hybride qui
est comme tel et quiil restera
c'est-à-dire un hybride de la méthode
communautaire originale inventée dans
les années 50 qui a subi une forme de
parlementarisation avec le Parlement
européen les élections européennes les
partis nationaux mais aussi un retour
des états avec le conseil le Conseil
européen et les parlements et les
parlements nationaux c'est inscrit dans
les traités je pense qu'il y a une forme
d'équilibre là le défaut de ça c'est que
c'est compliqué à comprendre mais en
même temps c'est très efficace et et je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas toucher cet
équilibre et c'est un peu notre point de
vue parmi les rapporteur de ne rien
proposer qui soit un changement radical
de la nature du système politique de
l'Union européenne qui qui doit rester à
l'articulation de ces trois approches
avec un rôle pour la commission la Cour
de justice un rôle pour le Parlement
européen un rôle pour les organes qui
représentent les États et de fait il y a
deux logiques de légitimation qui sont à
l'œuvre une qui est européenne via le
Parlement européen la Commission la cour
et une qui est nationale via le Conseil
le Conseil européen et les parlements
nationaux donc d'une certaine manière le
rôle des parlements nationaux n'est pas
évi évoqué dans notre rapport mais il
est en quelque sorte présent entre les
lignes euh pour pour la question les
questions de de Madame de Sidrac c'est
un rapport qui est relativement
technique parce que notre ambition était
vraiment de four fournir des éléments de
réflexion à destinataire des futurs
négociateurs on s'adresse
essentiellement aux parties prenantes au
débat on a essayé de le faire de manière
brève et pas trop jargonnante mais ça
reste relativement technique parce queon
ne voulait pas débattre de grandes idées
mais de questions qui pragmatiquement se
se se pose sur le le rapport des
citoyens à l'Union européenne je serait
pas aussi pessimiste que vousêes moi je
crois qu'on revient à l'Europe
fonctionnelle des années 50 les citoyens
ont l'opinion publique change assez
positivement vis-à-vis de l'Union
européenne parce qu'il y a ils sont de
nouveau amenés à comprendre à quoi elles
sert c'est l'Union européenne n'est pas
là simplement pour fabriquer des normes
qui n'ont aucun sens ou avoir des
institutions qui tournent à vide mais
elle fait des politiques pour penser la
transition numérique pour penser le
Green Deal pour penser les questions et
les enjeux de sécurité et je pense que
tant que l'Union européenne produira des
bien public elle pourra donner
satisfaction à une partie de de de
l'opinion publique ce qu'il faut
absolument éviter c'est de retomber dans
la séquence constitutionnelle des années
2000 à savoir réfléchir sur les
institutions sans réfléchir sur les
contenus les missions et les objectifs
parce que ça ça a été une erreur
politique à mon sens pour les les les
questions de du sénateur Kern sur la
capacité d'absorption de l'Union
européenne telle quelle elle est très
faible et c'est pour ça qu'il faut des
réformes majeures dans le cycle
législatif qui s'annonce 2024- 2029 si
ces réformes ne sont pas entreprises je
pense que l'Union européenne ne pourra
pas accueillir de nouveaux États tout
simplement parce qu'il faut changer les
politiques changer les institutions et
changer le fonctionnement du budget pour
s'adapter à ce nouveau contexte alors
s'élargir à tel ou tel état des des
Balcans occidentaux c'est pas un grand
enjeu mais s'élargir à l'Ukraine c'est
une toute autre affaire qui aura des des
des répercussions massives sur le budget
sur la politique régionale sur la
politique agricole il faut adapter ces
politiques à à à cela et ce débatl doit
être débutter parce que pour l'instant
on y est pas du tout sur l'adhésion tout
au rien alors il y a deux choses dans le
rapport il y a notre notre proposition
de quatre cercles qui est pas original
c'est c'est quelque chose dont on débat
depuis 30 ans de dire qu'il doit y avoir
l'Union européenne le 2ème cercle au
sein de cette union la possibilité pour
un nombre plus restreint d'État d'aller
beaucoup plus loin dans l'intégration
autour de l'Union un cercle de membres
associés pour créer une catégorie
homogène avec les États qui aujourd'hui
ont des rapports particuliers avec
l'Union comme la Suisse comme la Norvège
comme la Turquie même peut-être comme le
Royaume-Uni et enfin un 4e cercle qui
serait celui du continent avec la
communauté politique européenne et d'une
certaine manière l'élargissement doit
aussi se penser dans ce contexte avec
des États qui voudraient peut-être
d'abord accéder à un statut de memrees
associés avant de devenir des membres
pligners mais notre idée c'est
simplement que chaque État doit se
trouver dans le cercle où il a envie
d'être il est pas question de forcer les
Britanniques à revenir dans l'Union il
est pas question de les exclure
définitivement de tout arrangement mais
de proposer une structure claire où
chaque état a un niveau d'implication et
et et d'engagement ensuite on peut aussi
penser adhésion par étape qui a déjà été
pensé lors de la réforme du processus
d'élergissement de 2020 l'idée qu'on a
maintenant si grand paquet de
négociation et éventuellement la
possibilité pour un état candidat de
commencer à bénéficier d'une politique
sans attendre d'avoir tout fini sur les
autres c'est quelque chose qu'on qu'on
considère qui qui nous semble en plus
assez pragmatique car si on on attend
que les États candidat et boucler
l'ensemble négociations sur les six
paquets ça nous envoie à des euh des à
des
le calendrier sera très très long mais
néanmoins si on veut faire une adhésion
par étape il y a plusieurs conditions 1
on ne peut pas séparer l'État de droit
du marché intérieur on l'a déjà dit bon
l'idée qui consisterait à dire que très
rapidement les états candidats pourraent
être dans le marché intérieur mais sans
se préoccuper de la réforme de la
justice ou ou de de la protection des
droits fondamentaux me semble pas une
bonne idée deuxièmement il faut que ça
soit réversible l'État qui participe à
une politique parce qu'il dit qu'il est
prêt ou qu'il est reconnu comme prêt
doit y participer tant qu'il continue à
à faire les efforts qui sont attendus
troisièmement il faut qu'il y a un
calendrier précis il faut absolument
éviter une situation de gel où un état
participerait à telle ou telle politique
sans contentrait et et resterait dans
cet état parce que sinon là on va
rentrer dans l'Europe à la carte qui ne
sera pas gérable du point de vue
institutionnel et de la lisibilité pour
les questions de de madame la députée
linkelfield euh lenhel pardon madame la
sénatrice je fatigue
désolé aussi
sur la désaffection des citoyens là je
suis pas sûr les gens parlent avec
beaucoup d'angoisse des élections qui
qui s'annoncent l'année prochaine moi je
constate qu'en 2019 en France on a eu un
taux de participation aux européennes de
50 % et que au législativ en 2022 on a
eu 46 et en 2017 on a eu 47 donc on a
des députés européens qui en quelque
sorte sont mieux élus que les députés à
l'Assemblée nationale et personne ne va
contester après voilà je constate
simplement plus sérieusement qu'il y a
un déclin de la partici ipation dans
toutes les élections sauf les élections
européennes on a eu un rebond de de
participation pour les européennes en
2019 de 8 point de pourcentage ça fait
20 % c'est énorme ça veut dire que
confusément les citoyens comprennent
bien qu'il y a des enjeux importants qui
se passent dans les institutions
européennes et je dirais que les
citoyens quand on regarde plus
précisément les enquêtes d'opinion sont
critiques avec l'Union mais attaché au
principe de la participation de leur
pays à l'Union et on pourrait faire le
même constat avec le rapport aux
institutions en général les gens sont
très critiques vis-à-vis des élus mais
mais mais attachés à leurs institutions
et à la façon dont elles fonctionne sur
la la la politique étrangère pour
revenir à votre question madame la la
sénatrice euh on n'a pas proposé de
sortir de l'unanimité pour les grandes
décisions tout simplement parce que
l'Union européenne n'est pas une
fédération elle est composée de 27 États
très attaché à leur souveraineté très
attaché à leur politique étrangère quand
bien même on voudrait avoir de la
majorité qualifiée pour les grandes
décisions de politique étrangère ce qui
risquerait de se passer c'est qu'on
aurait un sommet européen une décision à
la majorité qualifiée pour un nouveau
train de sanction contre la Russie et
trois ou quatre membres du Conseil
européen qui en sortant irait dire au
médias on m'a forcé la main j'ai été mis
en minorité je ne me sens pas concerné
par cette décision donc je pense que la
majorité qualifiée est un outil qui est
adapté à certains types de décisions
mais pas à d'autres de la même manière
que dans nos institutions françaises on
a peut plus facilement changer une loi
lambda que la Constitution et que les
règles de majorité ne sont pas ne sont
pas les mêmes sur l'existence ou pas
d'un débat franco-allemand dans le
groupe simplement ce que je voulais dire
c'est qu'il y a peut-être une tendance
française à avoir une vision plus
intergouvernementale de l'intégration
européenne plus gaulienne un peu à la
Macron et du côté allemand peut-être
plus une pensée qui amènerait à
rapprocher les institutions européennes
et d'institution fédérales et on n'
jamais eu ce type de débat entre nous ce
qui était plutôt une bonne surprise ça
nous a évité les soucis sur les
questions de de de madame la sénatrice
Boyer euh la possibilité ou pas de
l'Union d'importer des pays avec des
conflits évidemment c'est une
problématique très importante là je
crois qu'il y a deux choses les États
qui ont un conflit avec un autre État
candidat ou avec un État membre de
l'Union européenne là il faut une
solution à ces conflits avant l'entré
dans l'Union par contre les états qui
ont un conflit avec un État tiers par
exemple comme la Russie là il faut
trouver les solutions parce qu'on ne
peut pas donner les clés de
l'élargissement à Monsieur Poutine qui
déciderait si l'élargissement est
possible ou pas alors évidemment c'est
des questions qui doivent être traitées
très sérieusement moi je pense qu'on
peut pas faire rentrer un état dans
l'Union européenne mais pour des
situations comme la situation par
exemple de la Moldavie avec la
Transnistrie je pense qu'il doit être
possible de faire rentrer cet état dans
l'Union européenne sans attendre une
hypothétique solution à ce conflit qui
n'a pas de solution évidente sur
l'Arménie Daniela vous
répondra sur la la les questions du
sénateur Marie sur le sur le calendrier
là peut-être Daniel Schwarzer en parlera
davantage je pense que avant l'élection
il y a une chose qu'il faut absolument
faireon c'est une conviction personnelle
c'est avoir un accord politique sur la
procédure de désignation de la
présidente ou du président de la
commission là les traités sont de ce
point de vue à mon sens mal rédigé parce
que il y a une incertitude sur qui
choisit le président la présidente et la
règle que le Parlement européen doit
élire cette personne à la majorité des
membres ça veut dire dans le futur
Parlement à 720 361 députés ça veut dire
que tous les abstentionnistes et tous
les absents votent contre c'est
difficile Madame Van derlen n'a eu une
majorité que de se voix moi je suis
assez inquiet s'il venait que le Conseil
européen propose un candidat que le
Parlement européen ne soit pas très
enthousiaste par rapport à ce candidat
ce candidat n'aura pas la majorité et on
rentrera dans une crise institutionnelle
longue donc nous n'avons pas proposé une
institutionnalisation de la procédure d
des Spitzen candidaten mais il faut un
accord politique entre le Conseil
européen le Parlement ou les groupes
politiques sur cette question pour
éviter une catastrophe sur la révision
des traités c'est une question dont on a
beaucoup débattu on propose six
scénarios de révision là les choses sont
assez complexes en gros il y a trois
approches la vraie révision selon ce qui
est prévu dans les les traités avec une
convention des référendum
potentiellement dans un certain nombre
d'États à titre personnel je suis
favorable à ça il y a un vrai risque
politique mais je pense que les citoyens
sont des gens raisonnables et qu'il faut
ouvrir le débat sur l'élargissement et
sur la réforme des traités faire preuve
de pédagogie et ne pas laisser ce sujet
à l'extrême droite et à l'extrême gauche
qui en ont parfois une approche un peu
biaisée la deuxième approche ça serait
une révision des traités via les traités
d'accession car qui dit élargissement
dit traité il faut modifier les traités
existants et dans les traités
d'accession on peut mettre un certain
nombre de réformes institutionnelles
modifier la composition du Parlement de
la commission que sais-je enfin trème
solution qui est la solution de repli
s'il y a des blocages avoir un traité ad
hoc qui serait hors Union Européenne
rien ninterdit aux États ou un certain
nombre d'états-membres d'aller bricoler
quelque chose dans l'intergouvernemental
ça n'est pas souhaitable mais c'est
peut-être une solution de repli si on a
des véaux durables d'un ou plusieurs
États membres enfin pour finir avec la
la la question de de Madame la la
sénatrice Jourda sur l'attitude des
peuples des des des pays candidats c'est
une très bonne question alors chaque
pays a sa propre procédure pour valider
un éventuel élargissement à l'Union
européenne à titre personnel je pense
que le référendum s'impose pour une
décision aussi importante pour l'avenir
de de C citoyens on sait qu'il y a des
pays qui sont des pays qui sont divisés
de ce point de vue là ensuite ce qu'on
recommande dans dans notre rapport c'est
d'associer les citoyens des pays
candidats à la procédure d'élargissement
ce qui n'a pas été fait les précédentes
fois les précédentes fois on avait
vraiment le sentiment que c'était une
négociation qui n'impliquait que les
responsables politiques des États
parfois contre les citoyens parce que
ils étaient obligés de mener toute une
série de réformes très impopulaires et
et et on a bien vu que les les
responsables politiqu des pays candidats
dans les années 2000 ont perdu toutes
les élections parce que ils menaient des
des des réformes qui étaient ass assz
assez impopulaire je pense qu'il faut
renverser la vapeur associer les les
citoyens des pays candidats au processus
via les instruments de participation que
l'on a déjà de sorte qu'il soit impliqué
et que la pression soit davantage des
citoyens sur les responsables politiques
que
l'inverse donc je vais ajouter quelques
éléments euh pas beaucoup parce que
Olivier a répondu d'une manière très
complète aux questions euh d'abord les
pays en conflit et notre notre politique
d'élargissement alors vous avez évoqué
le cas de l'Arménie euh si on regarde
les six pays qui font partie du
partenariaat
occidental oriental de de l'Union
européenne il y a trois pays l'Ukraine
la Moldavie et la Géorgie qui depuis des
années ont renforcé les liens avec
l'Union européenne notamment la libre
circulation des en fait le le la fin des
visas pour l'Ukraine les traités de
partenariats qui incluent des liens
économiques plus étroites et d'autes
l'intégration dans des politiques
partielles et on voit que l'Arménie
l'Azerbaïjan et la bélarussie qui au
début était parmi les six pays à pied
égal euh n'ont pas choisi d'avancer
comme les trois autres c'est pour cela
que les trois premiers parmi ces six qui
ont qui ont qui sont candidats euh au
statut de candidat euh sont ont avancé
et notamment la Géorgie très
probablement va devenir candidat à
l'adhésion pour l'Arménie je pense la
porte n'est pas fermée mais les choix
stratégiques du gouvernement en place et
les liens avec la Russie pour l'instant
n'ont pas mis le pays dans la position
de demander le le statut de candidat je
me permets juste parce que je comprends
le fond de la question aussi dans sa
forme de Madame Jourda qui était euh de
dire finalement le statut changeant de
ces états les fait sortir et c'est une
question qu'on a eu hier soir avec
Didier Marie sur le programme de travail
de la commission le statut de ces états
finalement passant du statut Partenariat
oriental au statut de
candidat leur fait finalement de fait
quitter le Partenariat oriental par ce
qui rentre dans une autre
stratégie les traités resteront en place
mais ils ont une nouvelle qualité
politique parce qu'ils sont candidats
c'est-à-dire pour les deux pays pour
lesquels les négociations commencent
donc ils quittent donc ils vont quitter
je pense qu' enfin je pense pas qu'il il
puisse y
avoir une gestion parallèle à la fois du
parten les traités bilatéraux entre le
pays candidat et l'Union européenne
reste en place ou le début des
négociations va pas annuler les contr
contrats d'accord d'accord mais d'un
point de vue politique c'est un nouveau
statut évidemment parce que par qu'il y
aura des négociations il y aura des
contacts il y a peut-être même un
soutien administratif et cetera
comment oui oui oui d'autant plus madame
que ce qu'on demande dans la procédure
d'élargissement n'est pas du tout la
même chose que ce qu'on demande dans le
cadre du contrat d'association du
Partenariat oriental ce sont pas les
mêmes choses qui sont demandées voilà il
y aura des éléments en plus très
importants mais ça n'annule pas les
contrats qui sont en place d'accord
euh
deuxème élément que je voulais ajouter à
la question très très importante comment
est-ce qu'on peut penser à intégrer des
pays en conflit alors je pense que le
grand défi pour l'Union européenne sera
l'article
47 qui est une garantie de sécurité à
chaque membre de l'Union européenne la
France est le seul pays qui a évoqué cet
article après les attaques du Bataclan
c'est une clause de solidarité au sein
de l'Union européenne alors si on
s'imagine qu'on intègre un pays tel que
l'Ukraine qui restera peut-être sous une
pression forte de de la part de la
Russie il faudra avoir un cadre de
garantie sécuritaire qui va au-delà de
l'Union européenne parce qu'elle n'est
pas équipée pour cela c'est pour cela
que je pense et ça c'est pas dans notre
rapport parce que ça va au-delà du
mandat mais est important pour répondre
à la question on ne peut pas séparer la
question de l'adhésion à l'oton ou bien
un cadre de garantie sécuritaire si
c'est pas l'adhésion à l'OTAN mais quand
même un cadre de garantie sécuritaire de
sécurité et de défense pour les pays qui
vont intégrer l'Union européenne si la
Russie reste la menace qu'elle est
aujourd'hui parce que l'Union européenne
n'a pas les moyens de garantir la
sécurité et la défense de ses
États-membres et on a l'article de
solidarité qui les oblige et donc là il
y a une nouvelle situation géopolitique
dont on doit tenir compte
euh finalement je voulais ajouter un
élément euh à la question est-ce que oui
c'est un rapport sans doute technique et
en même temps je pense ce qui est dans
notre rapport et on a vu les réaction
par rapport à ces éléments c'est quand
même une tentative de développer un
narratif politique qui lit la question
de réformer l'Union européenne et de
l'élargir on a vu dans le groupe le fort
risque peut il peut y avoir une pression
forte pour avancer avec l'élargissement
sans tenir compte de la capacité de
l'Union européenne d'absorber les pays
membres et ça c'était aussi une question
quelle est la capacité de l'Union
européenne de l'absorber nous on a
traité de la question des questions
institutionnelles mais évidemment la
capacité d'absorber de nouveau pays ça
inclut euh la réforme des politiques euh
le financement euh des politiques et
notamment le soutien aux pays candidats
et une fois qu'ils seront dans l'Union
européenne ils seront sous le côté des
récipients nets du budget et finalement
la légitimité de cette de cette adhésion
à la fois dans les pays candidats mais
aussi au sein de l'Union européenne
c'est pour cela que nous on a développé
un narratif qui explique pourquoi les
deux doivent se présenter se préparer en
parallèle et pourquoi le nouveau
contexte géopolitique à l'extérieur de
l'UE et au sein de l'Union européenne
doit être tenu en compte et il faut
avoir un débat et on met beaucoup
d'accent sur le rôle des parlements et
les mécanismes de participation des
citoyens dans la procédure parce que si
on cache tous ces défis du public si on
n'engage pas le débat parlementaire et
le débat avec le grand public la
ratification des traités d'adhésion
risque de ne pas se faire et donc on
voit ça comme quelque chose qui doit
être à la fois
euh transparente et très engagée d'une
manière politique pour engager les
citoyens ça doit jouer dans les
élections européennes du Juin du mois de
juin de l'année prochaine et pour
répondre à la question qu'est-ce qui
doit se préparer avant cette date
d'élections
européennes j'attire votre attention sur
la page 49 je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais on a on a quand même fait
le tri euh parmi toutes nos propositions
pour mettre en avant ceux qui peuvent se
faire avant les élections européennes
parce qu'on pense que la situation après
les élections ne sera pas forcément plus
simple politiquement et donc tout ce
qu'on peut achever d'ici là devrait se
faire aussi pour démontrer c'est une
question de légitimation de l'Union
européenne que l'Union européenne puisse
répondre au défis et donc il vaut mieux
euh mettre en œuvre ce qu'on peut mettre
en œuvre avec le traité existant avant
les élections européennes et on aura un
argument de plus que l'Union européenne
se prépare au défi merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup vous voulez
ajouter des compléments non
parmi non
oui une question en fait qui est un
petit peu en relation avec la fin du de
de Madame Boyer qui qui parlait de
supranationalité on a une question qui
revient assez souvent ici en commission
c'est finalement les décisions de la de
la Cour de justice européenne de de
l'Union européenne qui quelquefois
supplente un peu notre notre droit
national euh et donc cette question
est-ce que vous avez eu à la à la
traiter par rapport justement à ces
questions
d'élargissement je pense que
l'idée de de primoté du droit européen
sur le droit national et d'autorité des
décisions de la Cour de justice est
fondamental pour l'intégration
européenne l'intégration européenne
finalement c'est un projet économique
sans politique et qui fonctionne qu'avec
du droit si le droit européen n'a pas
prévalence sur le sur le droit national
tout tombe en l'espace de 6 mois je
pense qu'il en serait fini de
l'intégration européenne parce que si
tel pays commence à ne plus respecter
tel pan du droit social européen et
l'autre le chacun va faire son choix et
la la la confiance mutuelle sur laquelle
repose tout l'édifice serait ruiné car
l'Union européenne c'est pas une
fédération elle n' pas d'administration
déconcentrée elle n'a pas de système de
cours déconcentré donc c'est vraiment la
jurisprudence de la Cour de justice et
ces décisions qui fait qui fait tenir
tout le système néanmoins il y a un vrai
sujet ici à savoir qu'il y a de plus en
plus de contestation de cette de ces
décisions de de la Cour de justice et
d'interrogation par rapport à leur sens
et c'est c'est la raison pour laquelle
on avait introduit dans le dans le
rapport cette idée d'une comment on
appelait ça une chambre
une chambre des cours de des cours de
justice qui serait pas du tout un organe
qui viendrait décider à la place de la
Cour de justice mais qui serait un peu
comme la COSAC un lieu de d'échange de
dialogue de socialisation entre les
juges de différents niveaux pour que
simplement la l'information circule
parce que si on examine les choses à
l'échelle globale on voit que du côté
des exécutifs on a beaucoup d'organes où
les ministres sont amenés où les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement à discuter
entre eux le Conseil le Conseil européen
tout ça permet un échange constant du
côté des parlements ça commence à à être
beaucoup le cas aussi la COSAC les
procédures de carton jaune de carton
orange sont l'occasion de nombreux
échanges entre les parlementaires mais
du côté des cours on a rien et donc ça
crée je crois des tensions et des
malentendu entre les différents niveaux
de juridiction et cette chambre aurait
cette vertu de socialisation et de
pédagogie Daniel non pas
d'Ajou au-delà de la consultation
préjudicielle par exemple donc sous
forme d'un il faut un vrai espace de
débat qui ne n'aboutisse à aucune
décision mais qui permet mettre
simplement au perti en présence de se
parler parce que pour l'instant les
choses se font il y a pas de vrais débat
et notamment du côté des juges
constitutionnels qui dans un certain
nombre de pays se plaignent de des
prétions de la Cour de justice à
trancher le droit contre le contre leur
avis il y a pas de vrai dialogue avec
les les les juge de Luxembourg et là je
pense aussi que c'est un un effet enfin
c'est une nécessité démocratique
c'est-à-dire s'ans tenir à une stricte
approche juridique ça ne tient plus car
à un moment donné il faut tenir compte
aussi des des forces sociales et de la
réalité des choses et il faut ajouter un
peu de de liant de la même manière qu'on
l'a fait avec les parlements nationaux
depuis le début des années 90 il faut le
faire maintenant avec les
cours bien merci on est dans les temps
mais je pense que il faudra qu'on ait
une une nouvelle conversation sur sur
justement la relation parlements
nationaux et et institutions européennes
je vous ai dit moi système coszak même
si vous considérez qu'il faut pas trop
toucher à ces structure ça reste quand
même
voilà c'est une belle endormie voilà
plus sur laquelle le Parlement européen
est en train de de de de mettre la main
mise donc il faut être assez vigilant
par rapport à ça si on veut encore nous
parlements nationaux vraiment exister
dans une Europe qui serait élargie et
qui serait encore plus encore plus
prignante merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci à
vous